hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welterbe bereits aus dieser küche aus
der türkei im video gedreht meinen
session band ihr bereits und heutige zum
türkisches konzert und zwar liebig
zeitschriften und in diesen rezepten
zeitschrift und zu stöbern
jetzt habe ich mir aus der türkei dieses
sommers of la geburt und ein paar andere
die hier und irgendwo rumliegen und aus
diesem rezept habe ich mir jetzt gedacht
mach' ich etwas saisonales eine
gratis-app mittlerweile gewachsen
dazu entschlossen ein konzept mit
lavendel zu machen und zwar gibt es hier
an winkel eis das sieht total lecker aus
aber es würde ich es nicht machen
sondern diese kleine teigtaschen und
weise ist es ein ganz kleiner teil mit
lavendel und in diesem teil werde ich
dann eine abkühlung machen
wir mussten jetzt grad der neuerung
wechseln männern und nämlich gewaltig
aus ihrem vater vielleicht gefangen und
jetzt steht meiner bezaubernden hintere
kamera und wie man heute weiß natürlich
immer so dass die ein semester lang
keine gramm angaben sondern das ertasten
und bessern abmessen sowie eben zum
beispiel die amerikanischen rezepte auf
ich hab das jetzt auch so mit tassen
gemacht aber es zeigt euch natürlich
auch wie viel gramm
dass es dann so in etwa ist und zwar
zeige ich euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten
für den teig und dafür die füllung für
den teig brauchen wir 400 gramm mehl ein
paar kubach punkt vor eine packung
vanillezucker 1 glas zug hat es im etwa
100 gramm 250 gramm butter die ist
zimmer waren zwei esslöffel gut ganz
normaler naturjoghurt und ein teelöffel
lavendel getrockneten das sage ich
gleich noch was dazu und für die kühlung
brauchen
erfrieren das sind ganz normal ganz
kleine und ihr seht auch elemente die
sind total und verdeckt das ist einfach
so wie hier auf dem markt ebenso ein
bisschen ganz natürlichen früchte nicht
behandeltes und viel zucker als
probieren wenn ich einen zuckersüßen
kaymer und zwar ist es was typisch ist
ihr könnt aber auch nach vorne und
schmand oder creme fraiche benutzen und
auch hier benutzen wir wieder lavendel
und zwar einen esslöffel ich hab hier
auf dem markt von 50 gramm wendel
gekauft ich weiß aber auch dass jenson
button haben oder auf dem balkon das
dürft ihr auch benutzen oder danach
handymarkt gäste einfach weg und zwar
richtig ist ganz toll und ich übrigens
auch
und da kommen dann auch keine motten in
der zweiter stelle
ich habe jetzt für diese 5,2 liter
gezahlt
dann könnt ihr jetzt einfach alle
zutaten neben mehl zucker zu gut
wendel und da entfernt ist aber noch für
diese stelle möchte ich nicht im
teilhaben
es wird der teig einfach verknetet
und so sollte der titans aussehen als
song richtig schöner reicher den dass
ich jetzt stehen bereiten in dieser zeit
die birnen habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält und werde sie jetzt einfach
viertel damit ich das kerngehäuse
entfernen kann
und normalerweise würde ich die birne
treiben also zu raspeln damit eben
kleine stücke entstehen aber da ich hier
in dieser küche nur dieser mini gehabt
wollte ich mir das nicht antun und wehrt
die billetts einfach mit einem messer
kleinen schneiden in kleine würfel
ihr könnt also die birnen damit
schneller geht rein oder eben würfeln
also daher wichtig dass es mit dem
alligator gemacht aber hier habe ich das
jetzt einfach mit dem messer ganz klein
geschnitten in mini würfel gebe dann die
birnen in einem kleinen topf und lasst
sie bei mittlerer hitze etwas köcheln
da kommt jetzt natürlich auch gleich der
zucker mit dazu dann gebe ich noch
lavendel mit dazu und irgendwann wird
dann der birnensaft austreten und ich
lass dir jetzt so lange kochen bis
dieser saft fast vollständig verkauft
ist dann kommt noch kaymak oder eben
mascarpone mit dazu wird kurz berührt
und dann ist die füllung auch schon
bereit und ich nehme jetzt den teig und
werde in vier portionen 1
es war einfach so zu so einer rolle
formen
dann haben diese kugeln werde ich jetzt
ausrollen
die wiegen jeweils etwa 200 kamen und es
geht mit einem silikon aus hollstadt
viel besser weil da einfach nichts dran
kleben bleibt bei so holz aus und steht
mit dieser mail benutzen geht auch aber
dann wird der teig etwas trocken
schütteln so etwa mit dem durchmesser 25
zentimetern oder 20 besser gesagt jetzt
halt wäre ich das hier und schneidet
achten
jetzt nehme ich von dieser füllung etwa
einen teelöffel planung gibt es hier und
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr jetzt noch
etwas wahl müsse mit rein geben muss man
aber nicht
die hat jetzt einfach mein mann dort
sind zugestellt dann werden die hier
einfach so eingerollt hier können dass
sie zu drücken
also wir sinken ist es auch von
kinderleid dem ist nur beim ausrollen
darauf achten dass der teig ziemlich
falsch ist und sehr klebrig ist und ihr
eben ganz vorsichtig damit arbeiten
lässt diese fertigen teile ist mit 32
stück könnt ihr jetzt im ofen bei 160
grad für etwa 15 bis 30 minuten backen
bis die oberfläche leicht auf wird und
dann zeigt euch das endergebnis meine
taschen series fertig gebacken sehen so
aus als ehrten sehen sie sind nicht dumm
bild zu wollen sie auch sein also schön
hell hier am rand müssen sie ganz leicht
frauen seien statt könnt ihr sie
servieren hier an dieser stelle könnte
dies jetzt mit etwas puderzucker
bestäuben puderzucker habe ich jetzt
nicht da aber so schnecken es auf jeden
fall viel besser denn so sind sicher
reden als wir es gerne etwas weniger
tief nachlässt einfach so berger süße
haben möchte
coach noch etwas
und dann lasst ihr sie natürlich
abkühlen meine superstar und so könnt
ihr dann einfach genießen verschenken
oder zusammen mit anderen
ich hab ich mal wieder eben innen
aussehen bei mir sind sie jetzt noch
relativ warm und man kann ganz gut
riechen
das kann ich riechen aber ihr nicht
lavendel ist ziemlich intensiv vor
ob es noch heiss heisser was so gut wie
kein mobiliar oder eben keinen markt da
kann es natürlich weglassen dann würde
ich aber empfehlen bisschen schade mit
abzuwarten sind geschmack reinkommt
gerne auf zitronenschale in den zeit und
wenn ihr keine beere nacht übernehmen
das gelte für meine besser erinnert mich
immer sonntags über fenster gebrochen
hat unternehmen was ihr volk im winter
könnte auch zu nehmen und auch andere
müsse also ich finde es total lecker und
ich gehe jetzt verschenken schreibt euch
den bericht auf meinem blog mit den
rezepten mit der genauen mengenangaben
und stand sehe uns schon beim nächsten
mal wieder
und ja das war ein kleines türkisches
prozent aus der türkei des balls ich
freue mich auf eure kommentare